welcome to this video yeah some nice
opponents here in a row this is Graham
master dr. John none real chess legend
if you are a little bit of older you
probably really remember when he was one
of the top 10 players in the world in
the 80s and 1988-89 this kind of period
let's see what is playing is always been
a king's indian specialist he has in
fact him written a number of nowadays
really classic books on the Kings Indian
this was actually my main source back
then of of knowledge when I when I
learned the Kings Indian as a black
player so it's quite fun to play it
against him now with white okay I'm kind
of just just playing and not not knowing
stuff very well here maybe I'm okay so
my 24 but I have Bishop g5 I always
liked it to get this traded yeah let's
trade them and then see what we can do
maybe Bishop c4 making it difficult for
him to take ever I mean not that this is
very attractive anyway but and also have
c6 as a possible move cake steaks with
check but c6 you can go to c8 so I
played quickly which is good night be
five maybe four more pressure on d6 this
is a move let's let's play that not
spend ages
you can maybe just take it now you just
took it yeah giving giving up a little
bit on the light squares but
establishing this knight on d4 yeah
maybe bishop age 62 to where I don't
know where but to h6 first um they want
to play rook a one for trade yeah I
guess because Queen h4 at some point I
always have f3 but I want to play up
three only if you really provokes me to
do it okay here i was thinking Queen 87
as a move or a screen age for a really
big issue Queen age for f3 the check
yeah maybe I could I could be in some
back rank issues huh I wanted to click
play Queen a7 rally I wonder if g3 as a
move actually if I go g3s Queen cannot
but his screen might come come on a
light square so ok let's see 22 III is
also an idea if I play a three
yeah but the night on these three it's
not doing that much okay I can't play
that I think it weakens the light
squares but it's very dark squares dark
squares it's very difficult to play
without this move anyway as he will
attack the night at some point yeah so
this is what i expected i was thinking
maybe Queenie one simply i can trade
queens i I'm definitely I'm dad
definitely happy here yeah why not so
I'm still checking d6 there okay so he
just returned Queen g3 is nothing really
I can go be 54 queen bee form so that a
most nights it was no no idea okay I
have to be able to cook a ham I am
interesting i was thinking takes and
quinn before it's not such a big deal
okay but i have to i need to play this I
think attacking is weakness my bishop
looks kind of stupid now I really admit
that there yeah you see able to get his
Bishop to c5 but we need now I can go
Knight to f5 and then maybe Bishop e3
this kind of business
yeah so he decided to to do them to play
this retreat check on you three other
chick only three but it's not not that
terrible actually okay we'll put this
here check I mean if you place Bishop c5
i will take it's not a problem I get a B
pawn okay why did I don't need to check
actually still a very complicated
position so i have to retreat this i
guess it's kind of a liability on d3
difficult position then we don't really
cannot really say that I understand
what's going on check I'm sorry check I
go here let's see oh yes 93 because my
queen is unprotected this is actually a
threat okay so let's just go back this
is actually quite tricky if he does not
straight Queens I will play probably g4
and ask him about his pieces if they are
really well coordinated III is a bit of
a liability here or maybe 90 60
installing them what that's an ambitious
move there should be two or threatens g3
by this kind of
I can give this chick
time morning let's do this for 4G three
nice playing this very well I think I'm
starting to be worse maybe maybe check
oopsy to looks a bit tricky now can I
get this rook traded somehow not sure
what is threatening though directly this
one now we can move I simply overlooked
that more now boo that wasn't bad that
was bad I resigned oh I actually have a
perpetual check with rook wow what a
howler I just have a potential check in
ah yeah that was coming from the further
course from the earlier cause of the
game I felt like I'm being completely
outplayed and that did not really look
at my possible guys there yeah I played
that well I already had a position where
I think about here is a system at best
equal for black probably equal he had a
conversation with any played that nicely
maybe this wasn't a good idea allowing
this this v6 business it opened up the
the C file check
check the compounds to do this and then
take here this is quite funny computer
variation KX tix might actually be good
for wide but he can't play here which is
a mess I still a broke a 7 I completely
forgot about UK at seven after Bishop e2
I'm starting to be be much worse o Kings
ten he had what sorry I have to take
with the night check yeah this is
actually a mistake him he has to do this
and win 93 check is that as a disaster
and my rope is hanging of course yeah I
really didn't didn't defend this well
and I really overlooked that that
bishops if I was winning now this is
this thing I already did not did you not
look at this it's kind of kind of
embarrassing but it was really because I
felt like well we all played me and I
simply as if it wasn't on my radar at
all this check that's really pretty bad
and there's no way out of that it's
really just a job funny yeah but it's
certainly an interesting game thanks for
watching